Freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
ganz besonderen Video denn heute soll
hier in meiner Küche der vielleicht
beste smashburger Deutschlands entstehen
und das traue nicht ich mir zu sondern
ich habe heute die Jungs zuugast die den
besten smashburger Deutschlands machen
einmal hallo an die Jungs von was geht
ab wir haben einmal vadi einmal K mir
geht super wie geht's euch uns geht's
immer gut Schle schlecht Menschen geht
immer gut habch ausgetobt ich habe keine
Ahnung Leute was hier vor uns steht
deshalb führt uns mal ein bisschen durch
erzählt mal was ihr heute vorhabt denn
hier wird heute in meiner Küche ein
Kranker Burger entstehen genau das ist
der Plan also eigentlich wir haben kurz
überlegt ob wir quasi einfach so dir den
klassischen dich ins Geheimnis des Gold
smashbger einführen dann dachten wir
unser signature Burger ist so einfach
und smashbger mit Ketchup und Senf hast
du selber schon paar mal gemacht habe
ich nämlich auch alles gesehen in den
videosagu sehr abgefeiert ich nur so
bevor wir Smash ich habe ja deine Aktion
gesehen und nur ich will jetzt nicht
irgendwie so große Lobes aber du warst
auf jeden Fall einer der ersten die das
in Deutschland publik gemacht haben hör
mal zu Leute ne wirklich schreibt euch
das hinter die Ohren bevor wir den Laden
aufgemacht haben haben wir schon dein
Video auch mal gesehen gehabt so
deswegen habt ihr den
Laden Dach was der Max kann könen wir
schon lange darum dachten wir machen wir
mal was anderes ich weiß nicht du bist
ja in dieser Szene du kennst sich ja
auch ein bisschen aus darum haben wir
jetzt quasi zwei unserer Lieblingsburger
aus Amerika genommen und noch ein
bisschen perfektionier perfektionieren
genau also einmal quasi seven Street
Burger in New York der macht quasi nur
Single Cheeseburger und double
Cheeseburger mit ein cremigen Soße wo
Zwiebeln mitgebraten werden aber es so
super nasty und eben nicht mit Ketchup
und Senf und dann gibt's ja in LA gerade
der Most hyped Smash Burgers Burgers
sheeroll weißt du der macht zwar mit
Ketchup und S aber der hat ja dieses VAG
Pet hier und auch mit Zwiebeln gebraten
und der sieht ja so sehr schon so dirty
aus und so nasty wir machen quasi 50%
shortp 50% Chuck und dann nehmen wir von
ih noch 5% weg und dann kommen da 5 bis
10% Knochenmark rinderknochenmark mitin
kN ich sehe ich habe mir schon gedagt
was machen die Jungs mit den Knochen
hier das das wfen wir mit rein Krien den
WAG da kriegen wir den WAG nachgebaut
quasi und der wird quasi regional und
nachhaltig und vor allem special so ganz
alter ich geil hier se also ich habe
mich eh gefreut weil ich dachte die
Jungs war in der Stadt wir werden auch
für Sie ein Video drehen wo ich ein paar
Spots von mir zeige ich dachte mir die
sind da wir müssen was mit Burg machen
aber das ist ja
übelst viel geredet geiler weiB ich
würde sagen wir fangen an geilen
smashburger zu machen geil fangen wir an
fangen wir an mit was gürckchen ja also
eine Gurke als allererstes wieso wir
jetzt auch die Gurke selber einlegen
weil es total müselig ist einfach in
Deutschland auch selbst in der Metro
oder im Supermarkt es ist einfach echt
mühselig die richtige Gurke für Burger
zu finden immer zu süß und eine süße
Gurke ist so schon der erste große
Fehler bei einem richtig amerikanischen
Burger wir wollen ja dieses
kindheitsgefühl eines McDonald's oder
eines klassischen amerikanischen Burger
irgendwie wiedergeben und da kannst du
einfach keinen KIS schon nehmen so es
geht einfach irgendwie nicht darum
machen wir sie selber das ist jetzt
tatsächlich auch fast in Goldis Rezept
und normalerweise schneiden wir sie mit
so einem riffelschneider aber für den
Geschmack tut es ja kein Abbruch was
wichtig ist quasi wenn man Gurken
einlegt dass man sie vorher halt einmal
ansalzt man kann sie auch anzuckern aber
vor allem ist wichtig dass man sie
ansalzt das quasi kann jetzt ein
bisschen fachscheiße sagen aber es liegt
da daran wenn man jetzt den einlegefong
macht und den Halt salzt das quasi durch
die Osmos das quasi der Salz nicht
wieder rausgeht für diejenigen von euch
die die Jungs vielleicht gar nicht
kennen die betreiben den besten
smashb in Deutschland und haben aber
auch ein background in der Sterneküche
deshalb geht's hier auch mit Osmose und
also seit kurzem machen wir auch ein
Youtubekanal halben Jahr gen aber der
ist super geil muss ich euch aussprechen
also danke schön also wir fühlen uns
auch wirklich geehrt hier bei dir heute
zu sein also genau Salz man kann jetzt
auch ein bisschen Zucker reang geben
muss man aber nicht so das ist dann
Geschmackssache wir geben aber auch oft
noch mal ein bisschen Zucker rein ich
mach's jetzt mal nicht das lässt man
jetzt eigentlich zwei Stunden stehen ja
jetzt kommt natürlich der Fong das ist
auch jedem so ein bisschen
Geschmackssache würde ich sagen so wir
machen jetzt mal klassische Pickel quasi
und haben so unsere Mischung wir haben
jetzt italienischen Weißwein Essig ganz
wichtig jetzt ein also eigentlich würde
ich sogar so brandweinessig nehmen also
so wirklich so günstigen Essig okay ist
nicht schlecht der ist aber auch perfekt
dafür wenn man es zu Hause Hal so ein
bisschen feiner haben will ich würde nur
keinen weißen balsamiko nehmen weil der
zu viel Zucker wieder und dann gucken
wir einfach so ein bisschen Wasser ich
würde jetzt mal sagen so vier Teile ess
ich ein Teil Wasser oder drei Teile
Essig zwei Teile Wasser je nachdem dann
kommt rein ordentlich Salz Pepperoni das
ist so unser Ding so dass S so ganz
leichte Schärfe bekommen find ich geil
ganz bisschen warolder nur drei Körner
jamaicafeffer geil machen wir auch mit
rein davon kommt sogar ein bisschen mehr
rein und welche Zutat ich ziemlich geil
immer finde wie so butterdill Pickles
aus England senfsalt davon machen wir
ordentlich auch was rein chinesischer
knoblauuchf Ursprung in citruon ist nur
eine ze drin so FA für jeden faul und
ich sag dir ehrlich der schmeckt weniger
stinkig als dieser trockene alte
Knoblauch in Supermarkt ich ma noch zwei
kleine zwei gedill mit rein das war's
und jetzt kann jeder natürlich auch für
seinen Geschmack irgend
da eigentlich auch noch reinmachchen was
er will so also ist eigentlich dem auch
keine Grenzen gesetzt so ich habe auch
was vorbereitet soll ich die
gen Jungs das ist ein Traum hier also
wahnsinn das köchelt hier vor sich hin
finde ich immer so geil wenn man so ein
Topf hat paar Zutaten die dann einfach
alle ihren Geschmack reinbringen sieht
geil aus ihr habt gesehen geht in 0 kom
ni und am Ende hat man damit ein
besseres Produkt als man mit Geld kaufen
kann so sieht es dann aus wenn es fertig
ist ja le probiert dann probi ich auch
kanst du dir vorstellen wie es wird wenn
es halt länger also man kann sie eine
Nacht einlegen dann sind sie sauer wenn
du sie zwei Nächte einlegst dann hast du
den Geschmack der Gewürze noch mit drin
ach geil wir haben die Gurken uns fehlen
noch zwei Hauptbestandteile einmal das
Fleisch und einmal die Soße und um die
kümmern wir uns jetzt genau eigentlich
ist sozusagen die Idee die Grundidee
sowas wie eine Big Mac Soße oder
burgersoße snacksoße egal wie man sie
nennt also eine Soße auf Mayo Basis wir
dachten jetzt für zu Hause klar jeder
kennt das aus allen Videos mittlerweile
man Mayo ein bisschen Gurkenwasser ein
paar gehackte Gurken wir machen es jetzt
einfach so ein ganz kleinen Tick
gepimter also nicht nicht mit teuren
Zutat aber einfach ein ganz kleinen Tick
gepimter und unsere zwei special Zutaten
für diese Soße ist einmal ein ganz
kleinen Schuss Mangopüree wei ja aber
nicht dass das jetzt irgendwie asiatisch
oder so sch einfach nur so Fruchtigkeit
Fruch schön rund wird aber auf eine
andereart und Weise muss ich sagen das
kam so in die burgersße im Aqua rein so
haben so min haben so ein miniurger
gehabt also dre drei Sterne
dam oder war das
jetzt darf man das einfach so
raushenach dann als zweite sozusagen
special Zutat geschmortten Knoblauch
haben wir vorne im Ofen geschmort den
drücken wir dann einfach mit aus dann
kommt diese schöne Paste raus und die
vierte Zutat die dritte Geheimzutat wir
nehmen nämlich die geröstete Molke von
der nicht die ganze Butter wir nehmen
nur die geröstete
Molke das Filtern wir durch und das
kommt dann in die MA dazu kommen
natürlich noch so ein ganz kleiner
Schuss siraca etwas worchester Soße wir
machen eben kein Gurkenwasser rein weil
wir Sorge haben dass die Soße sonst zu
flüssig wird das schmälert natürlich
irgendwie so ein burgererlebnis die soll
immer schön cremig sein aber wenn die so
mit dem Saft ist alles rausfließt an der
Seite von der Soße das ist so ein
bisschen die Architektur eines Burgers
die muss eine bestimmte Festigkeit haben
so also ihr merkt Leute ich nehmeich
hier nicht zurück und lass mich bekochen
und mir ein geilen Burger machen sonder
ich arbeite auch wirklich selbst mit ich
rühre hier hab eine
knobuch sorry Max ich hab dir kurz die
Butter geklaut so jetzt seht ihr wie
dunkel das schon ist also kurz vom
verbrennen und jetzt fangen wir in dem
Papier fangen wir diese ganze Molke auf
so das tropft dann jetzt runter und
diese
Molke riecht schon echt so so karamellig
schon fast an der Grenze quasi aber wir
machen nur ganz bisschen rein oh geil
bisschen canpfeffer cfeffer ist die
Zutat die man die Sch cksße rankommt das
ganz ganz wichtig ganz bisschen also
nicht dass das jetzt in Geschmack ganz
bisschen wegen omami wegen der
fermentierten Chili alles so natürliches
Glutamat da noch mal so frei werden zu
lassen ma wir ein ganzen kleinen Schuss
auch mit rein ganz bisschen chinesische
Sojasoße helle kann man aber auch alles
andere nehmen aber das jetztchtig ich
rede davon Tropfen
so man so diese fein
nu asiatischen Soße schmeck das fühle
ich sehr weil ich finde so die besten
geschm Max Erlebnisse hat man wenn man
sagt oh was ist denn das noch und so man
probiert sich so D dururch zu testen man
checkt es aber nicht und dann hast du
eine Brand dann ist das so eine eine
geschmacksmarke ja so worchester ein
bisschen Pfeffer schön pfeffrig machen
und jetzt eine der geheimzutaten Mango
Püree das will ich probieren Bo schmeckt
das geil aber auch nicht mehr sonst
wird's irgendwann so zu krassen Touch
kriegen grüner Tabasco ist ein bisschen
milder hat einfach ein anderen Geschmack
weil der aus grünen halapenos ist wann
habt ihr die Soße überlegt beim
Einkaufen beim Einkaufen
so jetzt rühren wir das alles mal um und
hoffen dass es schmeckt kannst du z
Kamera h mal öffnen das jetzt sehr
dunkel ist hart an der Grenze ist aber
noch nicht verbrannt nicht nicht
erschrecken das sieht richtig nach so
einem Cheat coat für Geschmack aus und
jetzt wenn euch die Soße zu flüssig ist
habe ich einen kleinen special ganz
bisschen die wird ja nämlich wieder kalt
dadurch wird die Soße auf jeden Fall
wieder fester wenn du es kalt stellst
dann wenn ich kalt Stelle boah das
klingt so sieht pervers aus kling perers
alter Schwede Jungs nicht dass die Leute
wenn das Video sehen alle den Burger bei
euch ein zwei Restaurants aufmachen die
den Burger anbieten ja gut das wä
scheiße ist
geil zum Schluss kommt immer mehr ne
muss jetzt auch noch ein bisschen
durchziehen es ist wirklich große Kunst
was er hier macht Jungs geil so jetzt
kommen wir zum wichtigsten natürlich vom
Burger das Fleisch da haben FL und ich
uns gestern beim Einkauf eine geile
Mischung überlegt wir haben hier
shutroll ist halt richtig schön
marmoriert Inter muskuläres Fett direkt
drin hier haben wir halt das shortrip
dann kam uns gestern oh ja der beste
twist kam fladi natürlich drauf beim
Einkaufen knochenmarkt haben wir jetzt z
Stunden eingelegt damit das Blut
rausgeht und Salzwasser und das nehmen
wir einfach lösen wir rohe aus frieren
wir mit an kann das Auslösen ja einfach
mit Messer auf beiden leichten leicht
andrücken und dann einfach durchdrücken
so geht ganz einfach ist auf jeden Fall
ein Burger für
fortgeschritten se gesagt das wird
geschmacklich glaube ich gar nichts mehr
zu tun haben mit so einem Standard
Burger den ihr vielleicht mal irgendwie
bei einer Fastfood Kette gegessen habt
oder so weil das hier ist wirklich ganz
ganz hohes Niveau also war uns auch sehr
wichtig dass es halt vom Fleisch her was
besonderes für dich ist und nicht ein
vagu was irgendwie ganz normal für
mich sowas jetzt nicht gemeint aber dass
das Petty halt was besonderes ist was
halt nicht jeder zu Hause hat oder jeder
zweite laden und dadurch kam uns gestern
diese Mischung und wir haben machen das
eins zu ein jeweils ein Kilo und werden
so ungefäh 100 g knochenmar also ich bin
ganz ehrlich ich glaube wenn der Burger
so geil wird wie ich mir das gerade
vorstelle ich habe die Soße ja schon
getestet dann müsst ihr eigentlich mal
für einen Tag den
hatten wir vorhin auf
weg ich glaube nicht D D das werden die
Leute nicht akzeptieren dass sie den
nicht okay du hast da schon was vor
heute morgen schnell ganz wichtig beim
Wolfen das kann ich auch mal sagen weil
da kenne ich mich auch ein bisschen aus
dass man das Fleisch vorher ein bisschen
kühlt denn das habt Ihr mir gesagt man
wolft ist doppelt wichtig beim
smashburger und so können wir das
einfach in den Wolf hauen der Wolf wird
nicht so schnell warm weil wenn er warm
wird dann schlimmsten g das schon irg
das wird fast so eine weiße Paste
Teewurst
[Musik]
genau auch nicht zu pressen einfach
ganzer wir sind soweit die Jungs haben
gerade einen Testlauf gemacht und sind
jetzt in der Position dass sie sagen
jetzt können wir den krassesten Burger
machen alles ist vorbereitet freue mich
einf n das Ding zu essen deshalb macht
eure Magie klapp es wird klappen wird
schon funktionieren also entweder man
hatte jetzt flüssige Butter wir haben
jetzt einfach zimmerwarme Butter
schmieren das Brötchen gut ein also
wichtig dass da ordentlich Butter drauf
ist ein bisschen
aufgeregt in der Arbeit kein Burger wir
haben noch mehr Versuche
DAV aber alleine auch wie du die ganzen
bälchen hier penibel mit Waage abgewogen
ja so nenne ich ein perfekt gerüstetes
burgerbrö also wirklich hier finde ich
merkt man wirklich die Stärke von den
Martins die sind wirklich auch wie
karamellisiert ne zuer und das ist nicht
zu vergleichen mitem Ban was Deutschland
weit alles fast probiert und kommt
einfachider nichts dran so ja ankleben
muss es ja genau ein bisschen zu fettig
so also unten drunter darum klebt nicht
so gut
[Musik]
soick so jetzt Pfeffer und ich finde
wichtig viel Pfeffer jetzt kommt ein
krasser nicht wie beim Oklahoma Burger
sondern gewürfelt ich finde das passt
geiler als in so dicken Scheiben auch
echt nicht zu wenig so jetzt machen wir
ein paar Zwiebel noch an die Seite hier
lassen die einfach so ein bisschen
nebenbei vor sich hinbraten jede Einzel
Komponente ist on point die
selbstgemachten Gewürzgurken die
selbstgemachte Soße die perfekten
gekauften Bands und man kann wirklich
perfekt kaufen weil das sind sie halt
einfach und dazu noch riecht schon so
geil
neesk machen wir drei Gürkchen bei den
klein Zwiebelchen noch mit ganz leicht
Biss jetzt nehmen wir sie schon runter
und machen die hier drauf jetzt haben
die noch so ein ganz leichten Biss aber
haben so ganz bisschen Farben bekommen
warum ist Berlin so weit
weg was
meint mus leider
[Musik]
R WoW und da ist auch NS dem Zufall
überassen das hat perfekte Größe vom
Bann boah F besser aus als bei uns im
lad wenn man nicht wüsste was da gerade
alles passiert ist würd man denken okay
das ist so ein so so so ein Slider so
ein bisschen wie so ein kleiner genauso
muss der präsentiert werden auf so ein
papptelle ich drehe den hier noch einmal
für euch Leute weil ich sehe einfach nur
pure Schönheit in diesem Burger dann ist
es soweit darf ich proben wir sind
gespannt erstmal Jungs vielen lieben
Dank dass schön man kann es nicht anders
sagen dass ihr gezaubert habt und jetzt
bin ich gespannt ich darf ihn
essen h sich schon mal gut an der Crunch
ist da das Fleisch ist trotzdem fettig
sehr präsent die Pfeffernote trotzdem
saftig
nein frag nicht frag nicht ob der saftig
ist unglaublich ohne Witz geil und
wirklich das ist nicht ein Burger das
ist euer Burger weil ihr hab absolut
recht hät in Goldies Standard Smash
Burger gemacht das ist das tut dem
Unrecht wenn man sagt das ist
Standard versteht was ich meine aber das
hier ist wirklich eine außergewöhnliche
Kreation also ich finde ihn richtig geil
mir war wichtig dass der ganz einfach
aussieht dass der so das der
unspektakulär aussieht für mich
persönlich ist vielleicht der Pfeffer
bisschen zu dominant kann auch V
genauuf kommmen sein machen noch ein
ohne wür ich sagen aber ohne Witz von
der Saftigkeit vom Fleischgeschmack von
der Soße her ist das der krasseste
Burger den ich gegessen habe weil mit
dieser Liebe ne ihr wisst es selbst wenn
man man produziert ja Restaurant und
wenn man aber jemand hat der das Wissen
von dem Fastfood Betreiber hat aber sich
die Zeit nimmt vom homecook so das ist
geisteskrank Leute das tut mir auch leid
das das können wir nicht probieren das
ist crazy deshalb bin ich sehr sehr
dankbar
Runde 2 der Burger ist noch dünner
geworden noch knuspriger sieht er aus
hat weniger Pfeffer und jetzt habe ich
da schon Gefühl was mich erwartet alter
Schwede rein
[Musik]
hier ich weiß es passt jetzt sehr sehr
gut für den für den Plot vom Video ne es
passt sehr sehr gut aber ich würde lügen
wenn ich nicht sagen würde dass es
wahrscheinlich der beste Burger ist den
ich hier in Deutschland gegessen habe
krass geil also ohne Witz ganz großes
Kompliment g euch auch auch rein ich
muss nämlich selber
testen ist saftig der ist juicy wirklich
juicy letztens hat ich noch mal so ein
gehipten smashburger in London der war
nicht ansatzweise so saftig ganz leicht
B aber nur ganz leicht nicht von R und
die
Soße von der Soße kommen alle er
also das ist wirklich ein Burger der
würde jedem gefallen so der der der der
ist für jeden Gaumen etwas aber wenn du
viel probiert hast viel gegessen hast
dann checkst du die Nuancen das heißt
ohne Witz also ein Plus mit Stern danke
euch Jungs viel dan seh sehr ger wenn
ihr einen Burger probieren wollt der
annäher und so gut ist wie dieser dann
geht mal bei Goldies in Berlin vorbei
und ihr seid auch öfter in
Köln scha bei den Jungs auf YouTube
Kanal vorbei wirklich ganz vielen dan es
war eine Ehre euch danke schön war auch
schön hier zu sein ganz meinerseits
unsererseits ja K geht raus
geil